Biden is ruthlessly imposing his agenda
you want to hear you want to hear the
perfect example of the way Biden is
tossing his power around right now
there's a German family that is living
in the United States that actually
sought political Asylum we hear all the
time about how the millions and millions
of illegal aliens crossing our Southern
border they're actually political Asylum
Seekers when they're not they're mostly
fighting age young men who are economic
migrants who just want to make more
money the United
States very very few actual political
Asylum Seekers relative to the number of
illegals crossing the border in this
case we have a German family that did in
fact seek political Asylum because they
are Christians they're Evangelical
Protestants who wanted to homeschool
their kids didn't want to send their
kids to crazy German public schools that
were going to indoctrinate them and fill
their heads with all sorts of Lies so
homeschooling is practically illegal in
Germany at least where they were they
come to the United States they've been
here for 15 years they're here in my own
state of
Tennessee with the government's blessing
they've flourished they've done well
they're gainfully employed they're they
have lots of kids they dress properly
they behave well they're law- abiding
they they did everything
right they didn't cross the border
illegally they're here with the
government's blessing
and Joe Biden is saying they got to be
deported Joe Biden is saying they got to
pack their bags get out of
here which which means their kids are
going to have to go back to those insane
schools the parents said that when they
sent their kids to these public schools
in Germany their whole personalities
changed they suffered health issues
while attending the public school
and any ordinary American knows that
that sort of thing happens because of
the nonsense that is taught in schools
and the deleterious effect that that
nonsense has on
kids they got to pack
up if this family were Venezuelan rather
than German they would be allowed to
stay they would would be called they
would be called Dreaming future brighty
dyed American
dreamers if this family were not a
family but just a pack of young fighting
age men from
Honduras who crossed the border
illegally paid off the cartels were
involved in all sorts of crime they'd be
allowed to stay they're just dreamers
they're just they're just seeking a
better life
here if this family were liberal rather
than conservative
if this family were secular rather than
Evangelical if this family were inclined
to vote Democrat rather than Republican
they would be called a wonderful
blessing of diversity to our nation to
show us the way into toward progress and
they would be allowed to
stay but because they are German
Evangelical conservative white family
homeschoolers they got to go they're the
enemy according to the Biden
Administration and the reason for this
is that politics is not abstract right
now go to genucell.com it is no secret
that we here at the daily wire love the
genus Cell Dark Spot Corrector now you
might be asking what this product even
does well do you have sunspots brown
spots discoloration or dry skin pretty
much everyone does with the genus Cell
Dark Spot Corrector you can watch those
blemishes disappear in front of your
very eyes Kimberly from Youngstown Ohio
says my skin has improved so much since
using genus cell on my face I love all
my genus cell products and my skin looks
younger now it's your turn to feel like
Kimberly but this sale is ending very
soon take advantage of genus cell's most
popular package which includes the Dark
Spot Corrector plus the classic genus
cell bags and puffiness treatment and
immediate effects for almost
77% off Jus cell is so confident in
their products that you you can try them
for yourself completely risk-free if you
don't see results in one day you'll get
your money back go to genucell.com
start looking years even decades younger
tomorrow say hello to the best skin that
you've ever had jus.com
jus.com
slns there are some conservatives some
very naive squishy conservatives who
believe that politics is totally
abstract and it's just about principles
floating in thin air which is why the
height of their political commentary and
activism is to huff and puff and throw
their hands up and say imagine if the
shoe were on the other foot and to say
well can you imagine if the roles were
reversed and to say this is UN this is a
double standard that's all they do I try
not I point out the hypocrisy when I can
but I also try to go a little further
than that because the Democrats know
that they know that it's unfair they
know that they're that they're playing
with two standards here they know what
the Democrats know that the
conservatives need to figure out is that
politics is not not abstract politics is
always about real particular people and
real particular groups of
people German homeschooler Evangelical
conservative family that's the
enemy they get
deported Venezuelan economic migrant
don't speak a lick of English don't know
anything about our culture easy to
manipulate easy to control hooked on the
welfare system
inclined to vote Democrat at least
generations down the line they're the
friend of this Administration and our
broader liberal regime that's how it
works horn hat guy gets a private tour
around the capital escorted by police
officers he's the enemy he's an
insurrectionist he's doing a coup d'a he
goes to prison for 41 months Jamal
Bowman pulls a fire alarm and it would
seem likely to me intentionally
obstructs an official Congressional
proceeding
oh he just didn't know he can't read
signs you expect a member of Congress to
know how to read you expect a member of
Congress to to have the the functional
IQ of a fourth grader and to know what
what words mean in in syntax in order
when it says emergency exit only push
only if you want the alarm to
ring oh he couldn't know that or more
likely he of course he did know that and
he just didn't think he'd get caught
well he's a friend he doesn't even get a
slap on the
wrist that's how it
works and as as long
as Democrats continue to acknowledge the
particular character of politics and
conservatives just think it's all
abstract principles floating in thin air
applying equally to
everybody we're going to continue to
lose we want principles and the ultimate
principle that we want is justice but
the way to get Justice in politics is
not to bury our heads in the sand and to
pretend that politics is practiced other
than as it is it's to recognize that it
is really about groups of of people and
teams and alliances when AOC refuses to
throw Bowman under the bus even though
we got him dead to rights we got him on
camera it's clear his day that guy did
it she doesn't she doesn't throw him
under the bus because they're on the
same team and in order to do anything in
politics you need to have teammates and
alliances and compatriots and you need
to work
together that's what we're seeing
here so they're going to deport the
German we're going to say well okay but
now you better Deport all those economic
migrants who are very likely to vote for
Democrats and who aren't Evangelical
homeschoolers yeah they're not going to
do that they're not going to do that so
what now every Republican should be
pushing to allow this family to stay
this family is exact this is the exact
type of family that should be granted
asylum in the United States Christians
fleeing religious
persecution in Europe where we don't
even take that many European immigrants
anymore the vast overwhelming majority
of immigrants that we take in are from
Latin America so if you want any kind of
fairness in our immigration system
surely you would say okay one of the
underrepresented groups that don't
really immigrate to the United States or
are not really allowed in maybe we
should allow them in every Republican
should be clamoring to let this family
stay with political Asylum boy what a
great clip that was now make sure that
you ring that Bell subscribe to the
Michael NS YouTube channel we'll see you
next time